[Music]
your pets could be feeling the effects
of inflation eight news now's jeremy
ford visited nevada's spca found
resources to help pet owners who may be
struggling to keep their furry friends
here at nevada spca there's rooms full
of loving cats
waiting to be adopted but while some
animal lovers might be looking to get
rid of their pets here there's resources
where they might not have to if a lot of
people are giving up their pets for
adoption then they should find good
homes and loving people to take them
today savannah urcioli is looking to
expand her family by adopting a cat
we've been looking for a cat for a while
because we have a little kitten at home
already and she needs a friend but
nevada spca executive director lori
herron tells me others are looking to
give up their pets 65 percent of our
intake is usually owner surrenders
anyway and we've had a lot of people
coming to us with even growing financial
need reasons include inflation and the
rising costs of food medical and general
pet care we're really seeing inflation
affect our pet owners there are
resources in our community we have a pet
pantry where we provide free dog and cat
food for pet owners in financial need
making it easier for owners to properly
care for their pets if you can help
other people donate or adopt like
savannah urcioli did this afternoon they
put us in the room with jacob the cat
and she was like i'm in love with him we
have to take him home
jeremy j ford live local now